the mountain between us is a new movie
starring Idris Elba and Kate Winslet and
is the story of strangers on a plane who
gets stranded on a mountaintop and they
have to try to survive all they have is
a dog and themselves some few supplies
and their conversation with each other
they hope to make it out of there alive
of course but at the same time they
don't really know a thing about each
other and they're strangers so they have
to learn how to support one another to
hopefully make it out of this really
terrible situation they're in so it's a
survival story about two people trying
to get through a very harsh side of
nature but it's really more of a romance
because these two characters have to
learn how to support one another when
they didn't expect to have to go through
this situation when they got on that
plane so as a survival film and a
romance I think the film fails on both
accounts the acting is terrific
Idris Elba and Kate Winslet are not
going to give bad performances and Idris
in particular is very captivating as
this man who has a past
that's very damaged that he hides and he
feels very haunted by it and as usual
Winslet is very good as well but this
isn't one of her best performances it's
certainly not one of interest his best
performances either but the problem with
this movie is that the convenience of
the things they happen upon and the
whole survival aspect of the film feels
kind of like they're not even really all
that anxious the actors rarely show too
much worry or too much nervousness they
happen upon supplies very easily they
spend three days in the body of this
plane that's crashed and the only reason
you even notice that is because Kate
Winslet says it's been three days after
walking through knee-deep snow Kate
Winslet once again says we've been at
this for three days and inexplicably the
swelling on her knee has gone down in
this time period am I to believe that's
because she's been walking in knee-deep
snow for three days they also have a dog
with them that never complains you
rarely see how the dog is surviving I
mean my dog doesn't want to walk in the
snow for more than 10 minutes let alone
three days and it's knee-deep for a
human so how do you think that is for a
dog a lot higher there's just a lot of
convenience to the server
ival aspect of this movie where it
doesn't really feel like they're
struggling all that much the romantic
side of it is where the film really
starts to fail though because you kind
of care for them and a lot of this has
to do with the fact that it's Idris Elba
and Kate Winslet two really fantastic
actors that I love and that most people
really like it and so you automatically
want to pull for them because you love
those actors but as characters they're
very weak and the romance aspect of it
is just very melodramatic this film has
one of the most corny final shots I've
seen all year there's one thing I
definitely want to talk about that I
took away from this movie and that's the
difference between cinematography and
directing this is a major difference in
something that a lot of people sometimes
combined as if it's the same thing a
director can say yes I would like you
mr. director of photography or mrs.
director of photography to please set up
the shot this way because this is how I
envisioned it and if you hire a good
cinematographer they're going to give
you a great image and this movie looks
great the cinematography is very good
but the directing isn't because it's the
director's job to communicate to the
cinematographer to set up beautiful
shots that work to provide energy that
make the film flow correctly that make
the pacing interesting that make the
scenes work in the way the story needs
them to a cinematographer will give you
a beautiful image but a great director
will tell the cinematographer how to put
all of those shots in a row to create a
feeling yes it does look great the
cinematography is good but the directing
is very bland which was disappointing
because anytime you have a movie with
actors of this caliber you want it to be
good but in the end it was a pretty
looking movie with some good
performances and a very bland romance
I'm gonna give the mountain between us a
c-minus
guys thank you so much as always for
watching look forward to more reviews
very soon and as always if you like this
you can click right here and get stuck
my nice
[Music]